welcome to a desperate playthrough of
eldon ring i'm calling it that because
this was recorded in pretty much the
last hour of the last day of the network
test so i was desperately trying to get
a good playthrough under my belt at the
last minute
in my last video i had 30 minutes to
showcase the game as best i could so i
spent a lot of time planning and playing
it out perfectly
for this playthrough i kind of had to
improvise a bit more
this fight with vare actually ended up
being a really good example of eldon
rings combat at its best
it uses all the new techniques like
guard counters and jumping attacks but
also you know the dark souls favorites
like just good spacing and weapon range
so apparently that guy's dialogue is
written by miyazaki himself
it's just funny to imagine him sitting
and writing dialogue that calls all of
his players maidenless runs and tells
them to go and die in a ditch
we kind of use this little ditch off to
the right to sneak past the tree
sentinel
actually one thing i want to test when
the game is out is if the bushes that
i'm sneaking through if they give you
extra stealth like they do in sakura i
get the sense that they do
anyway
in my last playthrough video i was hit
with a lot of comments criticizing the
game as looking too easy and i kind of
want to address that for a moment even
though this topic is very controversial
very complicated and there are just so
many variables like player skill or the
items you come across and use and
whether those items are overpowered or
underpowered in this beta
i just want to point out that that video
even though it's 30 minutes of unedited
gameplay it was pretty heavily planned
by me you know i had played the game for
around 24 hours at that point i was
pretty experienced with it i had 30
minutes to experience and show off most
of what this area has to offer and i
needed to meet my goal of reaching the
final boss so you know i chose items
that i liked and i planned to get the
powerful items that i knew would help me
get there this playthrough on the other
hand is rougher but that's good because
in the last video i couldn't afford to
mess up because i wouldn't be able to
get through and show you guys everything
in the allotted amount of time but this
time i strike out on random paths i set
high goals i fail i improvise i overcome
them sometimes and i feel like that is
way truer to the whole you know souls
experience and at the end of the day
that's what we want and this game has
that spark let me assure you
one goal i did have for this network
test playthrough was to power stance
some weapons so obviously i chose the
battle axe which is one of the few that
you can power stance by
starting with the champion class and
buying another battle axe from kali
oh i just remembered that's
that's why we killed white-faced vary at
the start of the game by the way you
guys must be wondering why we killed him
no we needed 500 extra runes in order to
buy the battle axe and all that other
stuff from kali
not that you really need an excuse to
kill that guy anyway he's kind of a dick
[Music]
he really screams at you here
i like it he's actually got a lot of
character which i think is important for
dragons because when you dine on a
dragon heart you get to use their
signature abilities and his is a raw
crabs are always going to be like one of
the scariest enemies in these games
because they're one of the few that can
outrun you and attack you at the same
time
you could just hear there
i don't know if you noticed but you
could hear a slam and the crab was right
behind me that whole time
terrifying
[Music]
so these playthrough videos are actually
quite useful for showing you guys areas
that i didn't get a chance to show off
in my previous ones
this is one of the cooler dungeons it's
huge and it's got a great theme it's got
that stone fang tunnel's theme from
demon souls
and it's pretty tough if you decide to
fight all the enemies here as well
especially if you don't two-hand your
weapon otherwise it'll just bounce off
their stone skin
okay i'm pretty sure that last attack
that that enemy did should have killed
me let's get an instant replay on that
i'm pretty sure i missed the iframe and
the attack went over my head as i rolled
so yeah i was feeling a bit intimidated
at this point in my playthrough after
that experience with the miner so i
decided
okay i need to get through this
i'm gonna stealth
and stealth works so well in this
dungeon like i guess all of the miners
are busy facing the wall and mining
although i guess by stealthing you don't
get to loot or that precious glint stone
that's embedded in the walls
so interestingly the main boss of this
area is hidden off that mid elevator
jump that was a statue of marika back
there
that's how you know there's a boss
coming
[Music]
so one thing i figured out is that
jumping attacks are very good against
these guys because they're a slow-moving
you know human-sized enemy you can cue
your jump attack before they get a
chance to start their own attack and it
staggers them as well
so yeah i ran past a fair amount of
stuff in this cave but i do feel like
that's actually a symptom of the network
test which was time restricted you know
in the full game you'll want to clear
the entire dungeon and loot everything
and properly invest in your character
not gonna lie that guy scared the hell
out of me the first time i played
uh it's a good thing i don't have face
cam anyway this is the first boss of the
limb grave tunnels
it's a stone digger troll
and the name implies that he was brought
down here long ago to mine enslaved like
a lot of his kin
[Music]
so you'll notice i summoned the noble
sorcerer for this fight and in this
fight i feel like you don't really want
melee summons because they'll just get
stomped by this boss the noble sorcerer
on the other hand he's at his best at a
distance
although his best
still isn't very good he kind of gets
destroyed by this boss once he gets
aggro but he's good at getting aggro and
pulling him away from you at really
critical moments so you can heal or get
some spells off
[Music]
okay i didn't
expect the second attack there
so i hope this is doing a good job of
convincing a few people at least that
the game retains difficulty in a lot of
places but what i'm starting to really
love about eldon ring you know after
going back and really reviewing and
thinking about a lot of my footage is
that it really makes you fight in
different ways quite well
like just taking this area as an example
during this run through i've learned
that one handing my weapon against these
enemies isn't going to work i've learned
the jumping attacks are great and if you
try to block this boss with a shield
that is not going to go well for you
which is different than the rest of the
network test because shields are very
very powerful and you basically need a
powerful shield to beat the main boss of
this network test
so i guess what i'm trying to say is
that you can get through this game
probably with one play style but
you're incentivized to
try different things and try different
play styles in order to have the best
chances
look at the boss turn right there the
noble sorcerer distracts him so well
and it lets me get off two incredible
dragon fires i love the projectile on
dragonfire just spews flame throughout
the cave and
leaves imprints all over the walls it's
crazy
so our sorcerer buddy really gets it
here but he's done his job well
[Music]
so that the dragon scale blade is our
reward for finishing this dungeon it's a
weapon that was forged from the memories
of dragon kin soldiers burnished with
the essence of draconic immortality alas
the dragonkin never attained immortality
and perish as mere imitations of the
ancient dragons
from software still playing with a lot
of the same concepts for dragons as they
do in their previous games
what i love about this moment when you
come out of the dungeon is that
it's raining now it's a different time
of day the world outside has progressed
you know regardless of what you're doing
inside that cave
i was so close to aggroing that crab i
remembered at the last second and i just
saw its breath coming up from the swamp
it's a cool detail
so i'm feeling a little bit confident or
suicidal so i decided to try and take on
akil the flying dragon
and i realize you can summon here
look at him
he's terrified he just runs away and
cowers
how can i beat this guy without my
sorcerer buddy you know i'm thinking so
i better like it
thank you for being a good distraction
i realized afterwards that the noble
summons or any of the summons that look
like the hollows from dark souls they
obviously have the same ai as the
enemies that they're the spirits of so
those enemies are coded to cower in fear
from huge dragons or certain enemies
specifically for the nobles though
there's actually a little burnt ruin on
that lake that agile dominates and it's
called the dragon burnt ruins and within
those ruins there's tons of nobles and
if you sneak around and listen to what
they're saying they're actually looking
over at where the dragon is and they're
chanting his name and worshiping him
[Music]
in a recent video i put out i did some
research on whether day or night or
weather effects affect your stealth
interestingly night does seem to improve
your stealth
but rain doesn't from what i could tell
which i feel like is a bit of a shame i
feel like that would be a dynamic way to
encourage your stealth regardless of the
time of day
anyway what we're creeping around now is
one of the same carriages that is pulled
by the two giants
off down the road i'll show them on
screen
interestingly we've tracked the path
they take and they drag that carriage
all the way down to this the gate side
ruins i assume it's the last stop before
it's taken up towards stormville castle
indicating that it's valuable loot for
those above
another interesting thing i show off now
is that
melaner can actually be summoned at i
think any overworld site of grace as
long as it's the third one you visit
that means they've put a lot of
different melaner cutscenes into the
game depending on which direction you
take in this open world remember the
network test kind of wars us off not
everyone will go in this direction
okay i forgot to get the map
and
i warped to the wrong place as a result
um the bare bones map that you do get is
pretty bad but it does show really rough
outlines of the path and it still shows
your warp points of course
so at this point i'm desperately trying
to figure out how to get enough runes to
buy a torch
torches are really important and i kind
of decide to sell the clothes off my
back here in order to get one
torches are good in a lot of the caves
especially the one we're headed to now
it's hard to get through without a torch
it gives those early dark souls 2 demo
vibes i'm sure a lot of you will
remember that
in the dungeon we just explored we
talked about how this game does a pretty
good job of motivating you to play in
different ways and torches are a great
example of that you know they force you
to take away your shield and they force
you to fight one handed a lot of the
time
unless you want to fight through the
cave in complete darkness which you know
is also doable so
i love that dynamic i love the way it
sort of switches up the gameplay
so we're heading down to a cave on the
beach that's filled with demi humans and
if we go that way we have to fight a
troll and trolls can be quite good at
knocking you off your horse and killing
you they can sort of shoot a sound wave
that instantly knocks you off
oh and on the right you can see that i
just looted some mushrooms mushrooms are
found in damp places and they're good
for crafting any type of firebomb type
item like a sleep pot or a holy water
pot
i have no money so i don't know why i
came here
that nomadic merchant back there he
sells a lot of really good items i'm
keen to learn more about the nomadic
merchant law
they're a tribe that has long been
spurned by the grace of gold
giving them a sort of kinship with us
the tarnished
so this is called the dissenters cave
and it's named that because there is an
npc out in the world
who was kicked out of this place
he is a demi human like a lot of the
creatures in here he's not quite human
i love how you can hear them screaming
from within the cave
i decide that guy's not really worth it
because there's more enemies down there
so i'll go this way
it's hard to say without testing but i
assume that having the torch out uh
increases your aggro range and decreases
your stealth
anyway i'll be quiet and i'll let you
soak in a bit of the atmosphere
[Music]
[Music]
what's really cool about this boss fight
is that you can actually initiate it
from stealth
i don't think there's ever been a fight
like that before has there
there's no fog gate at the entrance or
even at the exit so maybe you could
stealth all the way through
the enemies are patrolling after all
and i'm just waiting for the perfect
moment
i really should have pushed the
offensive on the boss
because
these enemies stagger you so bad when
you're trying to cast dragonfire i'm
trying to cleave them all down
but without poise it's not easy
so yeah the dissenters cave is not super
easy
i actually think there's a lot of ways
you can approach it though one way i'd
love to try would be with sleep arrows
just sleeping all the minor enemies and
maybe even the boss too
but at this point
it's time to cut our losses and try
somewhere else
you know failure can shape your journey
as well just like success can
i have a tendency in these games and i'm
sure a lot of you guys do it as well but
when i'm met with a difficult encounter
i'll just stubbornly try to beat it you
know to a fault i'll spend way too much
time on it when i could just leave and
come back and probably beat it faster a
lot of the time so now i'm you know just
taking in the scenery trying to think
about where to go next we should talk
about these octopus creatures actually
here i pick up the land octopus ovary
something you can see all over the flesh
of that creature it reads they eat
humans in order to bear young and theirs
is the blood that runs through these
ovaries so there's no coincidence
they're right outside the demi-human
cave
so right there was an invisible version
of those gray scarabs that give ashes of
war when you defeat them that one reads
ash of war determination and it's aptly
named because it takes a damn long time
to kill that thing for the first time
unless you use something like dragonfire
i don't know why i decided to bully this
guy but after reviewing this footage i'm
glad i did because i noticed there's a
little shipwreck there off to the left
and he's sitting by a campfire with a
bunch of supplies these guys strike me
as a very viking or at least raider type
of character and it strikes me that they
might have come here to the lands
between by boat there's actually a huge
shipwreck off the coast to my left here
as well
it's funny you know i haven't played the
network test version for that long but
it's impressive how much the environment
imprints on you for example here you can
actually hear an owl hooting
and if you use this sound effect to help
you find the owl you realize that it
gives you moon eggs which are a very
valuable craftable item there are just a
lot of little details like that and i
think being able to locate a lot of the
stuff on the map you know intuitively
has a lot to do with it having
no mini map and not many markers telling
you where to go you really have to rely
on landmarks to tell you where
interesting things are
like this smoldering giant
now i don't know why i thought fire
would be good against the literal fire
giant but it wasn't
one thing you might have noticed about
this giant is that he starts the fight
at half health and one thing you'll
notice about the environment is that
remains just like his appear to be just
littered all over the ground
put these things together and i'm pretty
sure they're implying that this giant
and many like him fell from the sky and
you know took damage when they landed as
a result
man this fight is so cinematic sometimes
he just flicked some boulders towards me
with his axe and it knocked some trees
over on the way and shattered against
this little outcrop of rock that i was
hiding behind
it's pretty amazing easy fight but an
awesome one
and when you learn more about the story
it just sort of adds more depth and
flavor to this character
i'm sure a lot of you have seen studio
ghibli's castle in the sky
and you can definitely tell that they've
pulled a lot of the law from that movie
i'm gonna have a couple of lore videos
on the network test alone and one of
them talks about eldon rings castle in
the sky so subscribe for that
i actually feel like eldon ring might be
addictive more than any other souls game
before it it just has these moments of
discovery and excitement and combat
interspersed with you know relaxing
while you ride around the world before
the only place you went to relax for
like the hub worlds and walking around
filing shrine and leveling up and buying
items that's one thing but
exploring the world on horseback and
just chilling that's
such a nice reprieve from the combat and
then when you find a dungeon or you find
something and you're excited about the
loot that you're gonna get from it that
feeling is addictive
right now i'm sort of desperately trying
to get 12 dexterity so that we can wield
the dragon scale blade that we got at
the very start it's another example of
how i didn't really plan out this
playthrough too well
let me skip ahead a little bit
just selling a bunch of items leveling
up and now i have the dragon scale blade
the dragon scale blade more than any
other item in the network test just
tells you that they're going to change
the location of certain item drops you
know there's no way this item was
dropped by a stone digger troll in my
opinion
and
i think it's also likely they'll change
like npc locations as well and
that's all just so great because one of
the guilts i have about showing off the
network test is that you know i might be
spoiling this for people but hopefully
this area changes pretty dramatically in
the full game
in fact a recent interview has actually
revealed that margaret the fell the boss
were about to face
he's actually a skippable encounter you
don't have to fight him which is strange
because
he's guarding the entrance to stormvale
castle
there must be another way in or around
this place
[Music]
[Music]
if you decide to roll through all of
margaret's attacks you know which a lot
of souls veterans do it's so tough it's
challenging so i summon help and i want
to show you what happens here
margaret pivots mid attack because he
gets hit by a glintstone pebble from my
summon now i don't know if all boss ai
works this way but it's actually a
decent way of using ranged summons to
your advantage you know if you're a
ranged build as well i imagine you could
sort of juggle boss aggro between you
because he really does seem to attack
the last person that hit him
and this is something i wish i realized
at this point
it's all right i got him pretty low my
sorcerer all finished the job
i actually love that guy so much
and that's what i was hoping would
happen with summons i feel like that's
the best case scenario you know you
don't want something that's overpowered
and finishes every fight for you
i
kind of personally just want a summon
that has a lot of character you know
something that cowers from dragons when
you don't expect it or leads to just
interesting situations like that and if
a summon is underpowered it leads to
situations like with margaret where the
summon can distract him at a key moment
and surprise you i feel like that's
really memorable
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
glorious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i feel like i played pretty well
there i mean i am dead but i have beaten
him before without using a shield and
without using that block method that i
keep mentioning but what happens if you
decide to fight margaret with two
summons that was the next question i had
and you know summoning traditionally
makes these games way way easier
i think the results of this will
surprise you
look at the damage i'm doing to him for
example
this fight is tough
even with summons remember also we
talked about before how margaret can
turn on a dime and attack you at a
moment's notice
while i'm busy throwing fireballs at
trees
and throwing fireballs at spears
one guy falls off the cliff
so it's just me and an enchanted night
now
and this enchanted knight he knows how
to beat this fight you know he's using
the 100 physical block shield and there
are instances where he just tries to
tank the boss for me you can tell but
because i'm the one dealing damage to
the boss a lot of the time he just keeps
going back to me
to be honest though i'm quite glad that
margaret seems more than capable of
taking out multiple summons this is no
cakewalk
although
i bet you could juggle him between you
if you use sorcery at range
anyway i'm curious if this video changed
some people's opinions about the
difficulty i'm glad i got to show
a more honest playthrough in a way i'm
really glad you guys seem to like the
last playthrough regardless i've
actually recorded quite a lot of
playthroughs like this one that take
interesting routes through the game so
if you want more content like this where
i kind of just chat about what's
happening on screen and my thoughts
about different parts of the game then
leave a like it's not like you can leave
a dislike anymore anyway but soon i'm
also going to be talking about the law
that's in the network test and there's
an insane amount i actually think those
videos might be a rare opportunity for
you to really sort of understand what's
happening and going on in the world
before you play the game so if that
sounds interesting subscribe i hope you
enjoy this small taste of what's to come
in february
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you